okay so here's a story from salon that
i've had here for a couple days and uh i
i certainly needed to mention
it says
uh as we go back to the abortion law
down in texas
it says as pro-choice and reproductive
health groups are scrambling to make
sense of texas's new near-total abortion
ban that went into effect this week it
appears their efforts to skirt the law
are getting an unexpected boost from one
organization in particular the satanic
temple
the supreme court on wednesday night
allowed the state to implement its ban
so on and so forth we know about that
enter the satanic temple the
non-theistic organization which is
headquartered in salem massachusetts
non-theistic in quotes there that's what
they call themselves they joined the
legal fray this week by sending a letter
to the u.s food and drug administration
demanding access to abortion pills for
its members the group has established an
abortion ritual
and is attempting to use the religious
freedom restoration act to argue that
its members should be allowed access to
abortion drugs for religious purposes
the satanic temple spokesperson lucian
greaves told the san antonio current
i am sure texas attorney general ken
paxton who famously spends a good deal
of his time composing press releases
about religious liberty issues in other
states will be proud to see that texas's
robust religious liberty laws which he
so vociferously champions will prevent
future abortion rituals from being
interrupted by superfluous government
restrictions meant only to shame and
harass those seeking an abortion now
you could say that this is uh that
there's a lot of trolling going on by
the satanic temple and that's
that it seems like that's how they spend
most of their time kind of like pita
that's they're they're there's in fact
there are a lot of comparisons you can
make between peta and the satanic temple
we won't get into all of them right here
but that's a show unto itself
but
probably the primary thing is they spent
a lot of time trolling so you could say
that that's what this is
i don't expect that this legal challenge
will really go anywhere
but
there's a real deep truth here and and
i'm i'm actually glad that
they're making this attempt assuming
that it's not going to work
because it's true
that abortion is in in essence a satanic
ritual
the only
misleading thing here is the idea that
you have to be
officially you know a member of the
satanic temple to take part in this
religious ritual or or to see it as such
um
what is a satanist
okay
a satanist follows their leader
satan
uh
in rejecting god
and saying i am going to worship myself
i don't want god i want myself so
satanism
uh it doesn't have to be you know there
is
there's the kind of theistic satanism
where we're literally worshiping the
devil
there's probably not a whole lot of that
happening not directly
and and the people who belong to the
satanic temple they'll tell you that no
we don't we don't like we don't
sacrifice goats on the altar
spill the blood and you know honor of
our sa of of lucifer
um
they'll be pretty direct to tell you no
this is just about celebrating us it's
about celebrating our you know our our
freedom
and that's what satanism is
so there are a lot of satanists in this
country who don't identify as
the people who believe in worshiping the
self that's what leftism is i you know
i've always said that i think leftism
and satanism are interchangeable they're
the same thing they are both a worship
an elevation of the self above all else
above truth above god above beauty you
know all that mat above reality itself
all that matters is the self
abortion is
the high sacrament
of
this satanic leftism
what other what higher sacrament could
there be
than a woman killing her own child for
her sake
saying that i care so much about my
convenience
and my pleasure
and my so-called freedom that i will
kill my own child i will sacrifice my
child on this altar the altar of the
cell
so they are it's a long way of saying
that i actually agree with them
that that abortion is in effect in a
religious ritual
but it should still be banned because
you're murdering a human being
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content